DID HE EXECUTE?
HE DID.
>> Sean: I SAW YOU AFTER EVERY
DEBATE.
>> AND HE GOT BETTER AND BETTER.
>> Sean: I'VE GOT TO TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING I NEVER THOUGHT
I WOULD TALK ABOUT, THIS IS
GOING TO BE A LONG-WINDED LEAD
UP TO A QUESTION.
I'VE BEEN POINTING OUT ON THIS
PROGRAM, 1873, MISHANDLING OF
INFORMATION, IT WOULD APPLY TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
IF I WAS SUBPOENAED FOR ALL OF
MY EMAILS AND I DELETED 33,000
AND I ASKED TO WASH MY HARD
DRIVE, NO ONE HEARD OF BLEACH
UNTIL HILLARY CLINTON AND THEY
BUSTED UP ALL MY DEVICES THE WAY
SHE HAD HAPPENED.
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF AN
EXONERATION BEING WRITTEN IN MAY
BEFORE YOU INTERVIEW SEVEN KEY
WITNESSES AND THE MAIN PERSON
HILLARY CLINTON IN JULY, THE
PERSON THAT DOES THE INTERVIEW
HATES THE OPPONENT OF
HILLARY CLINTON AND THEY
EXONERATE HER FOR I BELIEVE
OBVIOUS FELONIES.
THEN THEY TALK ABOUT RUSSIA
COLLUSION, HILLARY CLINTON AND
THE DNC FUNNELED MONEY THROUGH A
LAW FIRM, PERKINS COIE, A
FOREIGN NATIONAL WE HEARD WASN'T
SUPPOSED TO BE INVOLVED IN OUR
ELECTIONS, CHRISTOPHER STEELE
GETS RUSSIAN SOURCES.
THE FBI NEVER VERIFIES IT, THEY
PRESENTED TO A FISA COURT TO SPY
ON AMERICAN CITIZENS, A DRUM
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE WEEKS BEFORE
AN ELECTION.
THEY NEVER VERIFIED, THEY NEVER
CORROBORATED TO, THEY NEVER TOLD
THE JUDGE IN THE ORIGINAL
APPLICATION, THREE SUBSEQUENT
APPLICATIONS THAT HILLARY PAID
FOR IT AND THEY NEVER VERIFIED
IT.
MR. MAYOR, WERE LOST BROKEN?
LET'S START WITH HILLARY.
>> YES.
13 CRIMES SHE COMMITTED, THEN WE
GOT UP TO ABOUT 18.
I'M SORRY, HILLARY, I KNOW
YOU'RE VERY DISAPPOINTED YOU
DIDN'T WIN.
BUT YOU'RE A CRIMINAL.
EQUAL JUSTICE WOULD MEAN YOU
SHOULD GO TO JAIL.
I DO NOT KNOW WHY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT INVESTIGATING.
>> Sean: THE JAMES COMEY?
>> JAMES COMEY FIXED THE WHOLE
CASE.
YOU CAN'T READ THAT STUPID
REPORT THAT HE WROTE THAT SAID
WERE NOT GOING TO PROSECUTE --
NO REASONABLE PROSECUTOR WOULD
INDICT HER.
NO HONEST REASONABLE PROSECUTOR
WOULD INDICT HER.
>> Sean: HE SAID YESTERDAY,
HILLARY DEEPLY RESPECTS THE RULE
OF LAW, JIM COMEY SAID THAT.
>> WHILE.
THIS IS A VERY PERVERTED MAN.
>> Sean: DO WE HAVE A TWO TO
YOUR DIGESTIVE SYSTEM IN?
>> WE HAVE ONE FOR HILLARY AND
ALL OF THOSE DEMOCRATS,
BILL CLINTON.
>> YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS, NOT JUST FOR PRESIDENT,
BUT OUR COUNTRY, THERE'S GOING
TO BE A WITCH HUNT AGAINST
REPUBLICANS.
YOU HAVE A MAN ON WHO LOST ALL
HIS MONEY, FOR WHAT REASON, HE
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
WRONG.
WE ARE LUCKY WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
WHO CAN FOCUS, IN A WAY IT
ALMOST HURTS HIM BECAUSE THEY
FEEL THEY CAN DO ANYTHING TO HIM
AND HE'S GOING TO REMAIN FOCUSED
ON NORTH KOREA, IRAN, HOW DO WE
HELP ISRAEL, WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT
TAXES?
SPEW ON THE ECONOMY HAS AN
INCREDIBLE STORY THE MEDIA NEVER
FOCUSES ON.
IF WE HAD THE HILLARY STANDARD,
IT WOULD NEVER BE UNDER OATH,
NEVER BE TRANSCRIBED, --
>> ALL THE WITNESSES THAT WOULD
BE FAVORABLE IN THE ROOM,
IMMUNIZED.
>> Sean: WE WRITE TO THE
EXONERATION BEFORE THE INTERVIEW
THEN WE WOULD DISAGREE         A
THEN WE WOULD DISAGREE         R
THEN WE WOULD DISAGREE         E
THEN WE WOULD DISAGREE         T
THEN WE WOULD DISAGREE         O
THEN WE WOULD DISAGREE         D
THEN WE WOULD DISAGREE         S
THEN WE WOULD DISAGREE         R
THEN WE WOULD DISAGREE         Y
INCRIMINATING EVIDENCE, THEN
EITHER YOU OR RUSH LIMBAUGH
WOULD DO THE INTERVIEW.
>> RUSH AND I WOULD NOT OBJECT.
>> Sean: IS A POLITICAL REPORT
SUGGESTING THAT MUELLER WOULD
CONSIDER IVANKA TRUMP A TARGET.
LOOK AT HOPE HICKS AS ONE
EXAMPLE.
SHE PAID MORE IN LAWYERS AND SHE
WAS EVER PAID.
>> I WISH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
COULD GET TO KNOW HER, SHE'S ONE
OF THE NICEST HUMAN BEINGS
YOU'RE EVER GOING TO MEET.
SHE IS VERY LOYAL TO
DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT WOULD SAY
THIS, SHE COULD STAND UP TO HIM
WHEN SHE HAD TO.
WHAT THEY DID TO HER IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
IVANKA TRUMP?
I WOULD GET ON MY CHARGER AND GO
INTO THE WRITERS ROOM WITH A
LANCE IF GO AFTER HIM.
HER.
IF THE GO AFTER HER, THE WHOLE
COUNTRY WILL TURN ON THEM.
GERRIT IS A FINE MAN, YOU KNOW
THAT.
MEN ARE DISPOSABLE.
A FINE WOMAN LIKE IVANKA?
COME ON.
>> Sean: LET'S BRING UP THE
ISSUES WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY ON THIS SHOW.
HILLARY CLINTON OBVIOUSLY
COMMITTED FELONIES, YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED THEM.
I BELIEVE AS YOU DO, JAMES COMEY
RINGS THAT.
THEY HATE THE PRESIDENT, THEY
HATED THE CANDIDATE, THEY TALK
ABOUT AN INSURANCE POLICY.
ANDREW McCABE LYING UNDER
OATH, JAMES COMEY LEAKING FOR
THE PURPOSE OF GETTING A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
>> ALSO COMEY AND McCABE
CONTRADICTING EACH OTHER.
ONE OF THEM HAS TO BE LYING.
I THINK COMEY IS LYING.
McCABE ISN'T A SITUATIONAL
LIAR.
IF THIS WERE AN EQUAL SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE, THEY WOULD ALL BE
PROSECUTED.
IT'S MY BIGGEST REGRET, I'M
SORRY TO SAY THIS, IN NOT HAVING
TAKEN THAT JOB.
>> Sean: MY BIGGEST REGRET AND
I LIKE JEFF SESSIONS, BUT HE
NEVER SHOULD HAVE RECUSED
HIMSELF.
>> HE NEVER SHOULD'VE APPOINTED
ROSENSTEIN.
>> Sean: I'VE NEVER HEARD OF
SOMEBODY BEING APPOINTED OR
CONFIRMED.
>> DO YOU KNOW THAT ROSENSTEIN
WAS WITH MUELLER THE DAY HE WAS
INTERVIEWED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO BE FBI DIRECTOR, KNEW THAT HE
WAS TURNED DOWN AND THEN
APPOINTED IN THE NEXT DAY?
>> Sean: DID YOU KNOW ROD
ROSENSTEIN ACCORDING TO REPORTS
THAT WE HAVE ON THIS PROGRAM
SIGNED OFF ON ONE OF THE FISA
EXTENSIONS?
THE ONE WITH THE UNVERIFIED
DOSSIER, THE BULK OF INFORMATION
AS THE GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO?
HE SIGNED OFF, DOES THAT NOT
CONFLICT WITH ALL OF THIS?
>> IS ALSO A WITNESS TO CRITICAL
INFORMATION.
FOR A JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT
PONTIFICATES -- I TOLD YOU.
THE ONLY CRIMES COMMITTED ARE BY
THE GOVERNMENT.
>> Sean: ANDREW McCABE IT
SAID WITHOUT THE DOSSIER, THERE
WOULD'VE BEEN A FISA APPLICATION
WOULD'VE BEEN A FISA APPLICATIO
APPLICATION.
I WOULD ASK YOU, DOESN'T THE FBI
I WOULD ASK YOU, DOESN'T THE FB
FBI, AND FBI PROTOCOL MANDATED
THAT THEY VERIFY, CORROBORATE
WHAT THEY PRESENT TO A FISA
JUDGE.
WOULDN'T IT BE MANDATORY TO
IDENTIFY THE DOSSIER WAS CREATED
BY AN OPPOSITION PARTY'S
CANDIDATE AND NOT AS A POLITICAL
ACTOR.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
INVASION OF PRIVACY ON NO BASIS
AT ALL.
IT'S A CIVIL RIGHTS VIOLATION.
>> Sean: UNREASONABLE SEARCH
AND SEIZURE.
>> IF THEY SEARCHED YOU OR ME
BASED ON THAT WE WOULD SUE THEM.
I WORK WITH GREAT ATTORNEYS
GENERAL, MY FRIEND -- GREAT
ADMIRATION FOR MICHAEL.
TO WATCH THIS HAPPEN UNDER A MAN
THAT I LOVE, JEFF SESSIONS, I
FEEL BAD.
I KNOW THE PRESIDENT IS
HEARTBROKEN OVER THIS, HE ISN'T
ANGRY, HE'S HEARTBROKEN.
THE TWO OF THEM SHOULD RECUSED R
THE TWO OF THEM SHOULD RECUSED D
THE TWO OF THEM SHOULD RECUSED E
THE TWO OF THEM SHOULD RECUSED M
THEMSELVES, SESSIONS AND
ROSENSTEIN.
WERE NOT SUPPOSED TO GET
CONVICTIONS, WERE SUPPOSED TO DO
JUSTICE.
>> Sean: LET ME STAY FOCUSED
ON THE ISA ISSUE COME UP ROD
ROSENSTEIN AFTER THEY SUBPOENAED
THE DOCUMENTS WANTED TO
PULVERIZE OFFICE BEGGING HIM NOT
TO RELEASE IT.
WE NEVER WOULD'VE HAD THE DEVIN
NUNES MEMO THAT SAID THE BULK OF
THE APPLICATION WAS THAT THE
DOSSIER HILLARY PAID FOR -- MY
QUESTION IS THIS.
NOT ONLY THAT, THERE WERE THREE
SUBSEQUENT RENEWALS WITH THE
SAME FALSE INFORMATION, THE SAME
LYING BY ADMISSION IF YOU WILL
BY NOT TELLING THE FISA JUDGES
THAT HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
>> Sean: IF I STAND UP IN
COURT AT SOMETIME IN THE NEXT
THREE OR FOUR MONTHS AND I RECIT
THREE OR FOUR MONTHS AND I RECIE
THESE BACK, I THINK THE JUDGES
ARE GOING TO LOOK AT ME AND SAY
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S TRUE.
HOW COULD THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
HAVE GONE SO FAR AWAY FROM THE
FAIR AND HONEST ADMINISTRATION
OF JUSTICE UNDER DECENT PEOPLE?
I THINK THE PRESSURE ON THEM WAS
SO GREAT, THEY JUST CAVED IN.
THERE IS ONE WAY TO REDEEM
THEMSELVES, GET CONTROL OF
THIS -- REMEMBER SENATOR STEVENS
CASE?
>> Sean: HE LOST AN ELECTION,
THEN THE JUDGE OVERTURNED AT ALL
BECAUSE THEY WITHHELD
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE.
>> BECAUSE OF GOVERNMENT
MISCONDUCT, THERE'S BEEN MORE
GOVERNMENT MISCONDUCT IN THIS
CASE AND THERE BEEN CONDUCT.
>> Sean: THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE ABOUT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
BRUSH AND COLLUSION.
>> GONE, HE'S BEEN CLEARED OF
THAT.
>> Sean: MY QUESTION IS ARE
YOU CONCERNED IN THE PROCESS OF
THIS WE DID DISCOVER THAT A
FOREIGN NATIONAL, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WAS PAID THROUGH
FUSION GPS, USED RUSSIAN SOURCES
THAT NOT ONLY WEREN'T
VERIFIED -- ARE YOU CONCERNED
THAT WAS PAID FOR, TO MANIPULATE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE LEAD
UP TO THE ELECTION?
>> ISN'T THAT CLOSER TO THE
MANDATE THAN MICHAEL:          M
MANDATE THAN MICHAEL:          C
MANDATE THAN MICHAEL:          A
MANDATE THAN MICHAEL:          L
MANDATE THAN MICHAEL:          C
MANDATE THAN MICHAEL:          H
MANDATE THAN MICHAEL:          N
MANDATE THAN MICHAEL:          ?
THAT MONEY WAS NOT CAMPAIGN
MONEY, SORRY.
I'M GIVING YOU A FACT THAT YOU
DON'T KNOW.
IT'S NOT CAMPAIGN MONEY.
NO CAMPAIGN FINANCE.
>> Sean: THEY FUNNELED IT
THROUGH A LAW FIRM.
>> THEY FUNNELED THROUGH A LAW
FIRM AND THE PRESIDENT REPAID IT
FIRM AND THE PRESIDENT REPAID I
IT.
>> Sean: THERE'S NO
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAW.
>> ZERO.
EVERYBODY WAS NERVOUS ABOUT THIS
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
I KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY HE PUT
INTO THAT CAMPAIGN AND I SAID
130,000, THEY COULD DO A COUPLE
OF CHECKS FOR 130,000.
WHEN I HEARD HIS RETAINER OF
130,000 HE WAS DOING THE WORK
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S HOW HE'S REPAYING IT WITH
A LITTLE PROFIT IN THE LITTLE
MARGIN.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT WHAT
ABOUT
STOMACH DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THIS?
>> HE KNEW HE WOULD TAKE CARE OF
THINGS LIKE THIS, LIKE I TAKE
CARE OF THIS WITH MY CLIENTS, I
DON'T BURDEN THEM WITH EVERY
SINGLE THING THAT COMES ALONG.
>> Sean: WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
THE RAID ON HIS OFFICE.
>> ONE OF THE REASONS WE WOULD
HESITATE TO COOPERATE ANY
FURTHER, AND I THINK THIS IS THE
BREAKDOWN WITH DOWD BACK IN
JANUARY THAT TOOK THEM BY
SURPRISE, THAT COULD BE BEYOND
ANYTHING -- THAT IS AN
OUTRAGEOUS VIOLATION OF
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE BEYOND
WHAT DONALD TRUMP'S
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE.